[Applause]
welcome to willie's wonderland
spend the night cleaning willie's
wonderland and i will pay to have your
car
fixed deal
you are officially on staff let's get
the hell out of here
i can't stand to hear a grown man scream
this place has a dark history
i know the [ __ ] story they told you
it's a lie
you're here to be a human sacrifice
have you been listening to a word i've
been saying
he's gonna die in here but he won't
listen to me
[Music]
machines got out
he's not trapped in here with them we're
trapped in here with him
[Music]
it's birthday time i enjoy a man a few
words
we never expected to have freedom or
independence or equality in this country
but it doesn't matter what the
challenges are you run through that wall
[Music]
whether you know it or not right here
right now
you are a coming of age story
mr alfred welcome to ap english i prefer
my stripper name
boogie
[Music]
no one believes in an asian basketball
player have mercy on muscle
it's a joke in this country we can cook
clean count real good but anything else
we picked last
cause i got it but if you stick to our
plans and we beat monk
we'll get our shot at the nba look
have mercy yo who is that
oh that's eleanor he could get it if he
stops staring
have mercy on me as a self-hate in china
man i was skeptical about boogie
i see you zaddy
come on back in the locker room
i'm sorry coach hawkins i'm principal
kodak not necessary
this is our culture alfred has parents
who value respect
and discipline and without them we are
nothing
i don't cry you don't want to know
what's going on in my house
my mom she's responsible but she doesn't
believe in me
my dad is irresponsible but he believes
in you
[Music]
i've got to represent i got five
thousand years of chinese history
it's a lot of pressure i know how you
feel
but you have a chance to change history
[Music]
i need you to fight for yourself the
same way you fight for being chinese
[Music]
this has always been about you you're
playing a beat monk
so what are you gonna do
hey jake can i get a large bottle of
that baiju
you know what make it too large
how can you drink like that i used to
complain that every day felt the same
and now every day is the same aj
i have died 144 times and every day ends
like this
but it doesn't matter not when you've
lost everything you've loved
renter man who's had me killed 150 times
the power to rewrite history is mine
heads up i know everything that's going
to happen
one thing that never changes what's up
pretty boy
a bunch of [ __ ] are killing me for
reasons that remain a mystery
i am guanyin and guanyin have done this
iron cry it's about you
roy can you hear me you can't explain it
right now but i'm gonna need your help
gemma the only woman i've ever loved and
who can stop this is still alive
i have to get killed hi roy over and
over again
until i'd save her you need to learn how
to fight with a sword
i would only have a day i think we get a
lot done in a day
been the busiest little beaver
i'm starting the death loop because of
you exactly
bring them all can do this
all day
[Applause]
[Music]
this is june 22nd 1961.
can you recall your earliest memories of
race
you grab that bat and you do what's
right i don't think so
this is in your blood all right this is
where you belong boy
montgomery's a pretty town another
pretty ugly side to it
[Music]
get out of here i was in a riot and i
walked
right through it unharmed what is the
point you're trying to make
maybe i could go around college campuses
talking to students about the neutral
cause
the hell do you think you're doing
son i'm starting to wonder if you are
aware of the poison
in the apple that you have bitten in
you know this movement is about more
than just voting rights we're trying to
change the world
you want to jeopardize your whole life
for some grand principle isn't that what
they're doing
some of these old boys around here they
really meant to do you some harm
i bet you ain't happy you came to
montgomery now boy
so what's gonna happen next
[Music]
[Music]
you got to draw the line somewhere you
stop right now they're gonna kill him
there's gonna come a time when something
really bad happens and you're gonna have
to decide which side you are
not choosing is a choice
ain't you supposed to be non-violent now
i'm having a real big problem with that
right now
oh my god are you kidding me what we are
going out tonight
cataclysm this place is like an adult
disneyland
shots are you supposed to be dj dream
catcher
are you worried about getting mobbed out
here why do you think i always wear a
mask
[Music]
so here's the deal we will get rid of
the body and you will walk away with
a compensation check we will take them
down
well we can't go in there guns blazing
we are better than that
we've got to be strong i don't want to
be strong
i want to be angry
go go
uh
oh
[Music]
are you okay
she said she was feeling better we see
that regularly with schizophrenia
but it can't be cured
[Music]
okay hanging in there
[Music]
honey your father's gonna take the door
off the hinges if you keep blocking it
[Music]
did you hear that there was a girl next
door screaming for help
ryan there's nobody out here there's a
little girl in your attic i saw her
there's no one up there she's lying
you're telling me that your neighbor
kidnapped a little girl and has her
chained in her attic
i just need you to trust me i do all
right
there's no one up there your mind is
just playing tricks on you
please stay away from that house this is
a serious accusation one that will
likely have equally serious consequences
[Music]
he said she works monday through friday
we've been helpful to mention it was at
our school
get it together
she's not real there's no one
up there my mind is just playing
[Music]
i don't care what if it was me i'm not
just gonna sit here
your mind is just playing tricks on you
[Music]
how long did you have this business we
have been here for 17 years
[Music]
it's not my fault you live like this no
more
what am i gonna leave behind i inherited
all this
debt and struggle for my parents because
their american dream fell apart
are you gonna work like this forever why
can't you respect my decision
[Music]
you ever wonder if her family is blessed
or cursed
and this is our story couldn't decide
for me but i'm not living wondering your
ministry
she tried to make my life perfect with
some laundry detergent
it's just the fate of being children of
immigrants and it's even embedded in our
ethnicity
in a form of a hyphen
tuesday january 1st 1856
with little pride and less hope
we begin the new year
[Music]
who is that good afternoon
i'm tally abigail
[Music]
i hope i'm not keeping you from
something i'm glad you've come
meeting you has made my day oh how
pleasant and uncommon it is to make
someone's day
i guess i'm supposed to offer a toast
what my husband means is he's so happy
to finally get together
did you miss me yes
[Music]
our farm is a slaughterhouse right now
my husband is killing his hawks
and i resolve to visit you so that there
would be something in my day other than
his meanness
so what do you think what do you think
about us i don't know how to put it into
words
it's been my experience that it's not
always those who show the least
you actually feel the least
well seven an earthquake knocked down
our house we're born an earthquake
the dread never fully went away what was
safe if the solid earth could do that
when the day is done my mind turns to
her and i think
why are we to be separated
i don't feel i have a wife i have
certain expectations and you have
certain duties
we shall sing like birds in the cage
we haven't seen you for days have you
been ill
it's happening are you in danger i would
die without you
do you know what memory it is that i
most cherish it's if you're turning to
me with that smile
once you realized that you were loved
astonishment and joy
astonishment and joy
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
leonardo
go down
[Applause]
[Music]
you